there are many questions which keep us
up at night is there an afterlife why
are we here and why is Belarus a thing
so Belarus is a country in Eastern
Europe sandwiched between Poland Russia
Ukraine and the Baltics it's also an
exceptionally young nation having only
become a fully independent state in 1991
so the name Belarus comes from the term
Belarus which means white Russia
historically much of modern-day Belarus
is lands were located within the Grand
Duchy of Lithuania here the Belarusians
were often referred to as Ruthenians but
this term was often a broad one which
applied to both them and the Ukrainians
in fact the people who lived there were
often refer to his evil it's veneer or
poly gastric the first traces of a
consistent Belarusian national identity
don't spring up until the 19th century
roughly when all of the other
nationalist movements were picking up -
during the 19th century Belarus was a
part of the Russian Empire after the
partition of Poland Lithuania and they
saw many changes brought about firstly
the ruling polish Catholic class were
removed from power and replaced with the
russian-speaking Orthodox one
secondly intellectuals within the
Russian Empire began to study the
Belarusian people to determine just how
differently were covertly that is
because the imperial government outlawed
the notion the Belarusians were distinct
people from Russians in the latter half
of the 19th century the Belarusians led
by constantiy Kalinowski revolted
against the Russians asserting their own
identity but this revolt was soon
crushed of course this doesn't
invalidate the belarusian claims of the
unique identity though it existed
whether or not the saint-petersburg
government wanted it to so as you'll
know world war 1 kicked off in 1914 and
this saw the status of belarus and its
people changed massively in a very short
period of time after pushing the
russians back to here the germans
created a puppet state the Belarusian
People's Republic this was short-lived
in the Russian Civil War in the
following polish-soviet war soared the
land divided like this with some of the
Belarusian lands going to Poland and the
rest going to the USSR the Belarusian
lands here were known as the Belarusian
Soviet Socialist Republic the B SSR was
enlarged twice the first was an internal
enlargement which reflected demographic
lines the second came with the USSR's
annexation of eastern Poland in the
lead-up to World War two after the dust
from that conflict had settled Belarus's
modern borders were established and
affirmed that said belarus wasn't
independent in any way barring some
politicking by stalin because as many of
you will know belarus along with ukraine
had their own seat
in the UN whilst being a part of the
USSR the reason West eyerly managed to
get these was that he refused to join
the new UN unless he was granted extra
seats since he was concerned that he
would be consistently outvoted by non
communist states this concession was
granted in the be SSR held its own seat
until the dissolution of the USSR in
1991 when it's seat was transferred to
modern Belarus so in conclusion the
origins of Belarus are blurred and
wrapped up in difficulties concerning
names and which state its culture is
rooted in was Belarus another successor
to the Grand Duchy of Lithuania or was
it a newcomer whose identity was forged
in opposition to those around it be
aware though that Belarus and its people
shouldn't be seen as some offshoot of
Russia and that their history is long
and varied Belarus is in many respects a
young country but it's people and the
many names have existed for much longer
I hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with extra thanks
to my patreon supporters which you can
see on screen and with an extra special
thanks to James Bissonnette David
archaeologist Ozark a flash Party Boyko
Rob Waterhouse Chris wicker Michael
Reynolds Gustav Swann David Silverman
spinning three plates
Maggie packs Kowski Christian check'
Anthony Beckett Ike Skye Chappell and
Winston K word
you